Ngày Mi Tăng Nga Bộ thông nhất hành có bố sách trắng chính sách mới,
sát định định hướng cùng tổn tại hoa đình và cùng phát triển trên mả đảo trụ tiền
thay thề cách tâm cận người áp lực và đối đầu, của chính quyền tình nhập.
Theo tại liệu chính quyền tổn thống li trên mèng đưa giáp bằng nguyên thách chính,
gồm tôn trọng hệ thống của trụ tiền không theo đuổi thống nhất bằng sắp nhập,
và thông tham gia có động thủ định.
Bộ này chứ biết đây là cơ sở để xử dự lòng tiên và sạm căn thử liên châu,
sách trắng nè một số biển phát cuộc thệ nhưng hình người chuyên đơn sản trở tiền,
dừng phát thành qua loa sọ biến giới và tự bất khối phục cành đối thoại.
Chính phục cũng định hôm nối lại thật thuận của sự liên châu kiến năm 2020.
Hành tiên nhớ nha cũng có bố sổ liệu trong tài liệu ở trở biết,
tần số sự giống thức thử khoa liên quan tình hoa mình với đối thoại tăng mạnh,
trong khi các nổi dung vệ nhân quyền châu tiên và người đau tổ giảm đáng cạnh.
Tuy nhiên theo dụn hấp, quan hiện liên châu dẫn vẫn được trạng thái gần như đong băng,
tài liệu có hội trở tiên châu biết, bình nhớn tí tục có hai miền là hai cuo gia thu địch
và đã lại bỏ nội dung thống nhất khỏi in pháp sờ đổi.